do not be celebrating christmas eve
this is
not sunnah
it takes you out of the fold of islam
but on a brighter note you know welcome
back to the channel we're doing the live
today we are missing
we are missing a body
that's all right
inshaallah he will come soon
and uh with that
we want to talk about christmas
in today's live stream i want to talk
about christmas
so
short answer as you said is no we cannot
we cannot right because because the
title of this podcast is can muslims
celebrate christmas
but if you guys want a nuanced answer
like we did for the birthday thing it's
coming up
so you know mashallah 20 viewers come on
let's get it up uh and smash the like
button if you guys are here 21 viewers i
know you're like a physics prof right so
if we got 21 viewers how many likes
should that be
minimum 200 bro minimum 200 bro i still
don't know how that makes sense bro but
uh he's a physics prof so it's not for
me to understand um aside from that uh a
lot of people ask are halloween's
permissible in islam birthday is
permissible so christmas is next bro
it's christmas eve today so
without further ado
i'm not a scholar on how are you a
scholar
all right then so let's let us speak bro
let him speak
[Music]
on the 25th of december called christmas
what is it really about can muslims and
christians and others partake in it or
not
so the first thing before we get into
opinions and things let's look at some
historic facts
where did the 25th of december come from
was this a day
that biblically jesus was born that is
not the case that is not the case if we
go back for example natural geographics
has a book an uncommon history of common
things
and if you look at any of the research
that we have seen whether it's on the
internet or in books about christmas
they write
that
christmas was not a part of the
christian faith
in fact for four centuries
after isla
ascension for four centuries
after jesus there was no such concept in
christianity
it's non-muslim research that for four
centuries after jesus there was no idea
of the 25th of december being tied to
jesus
so in fact if we look in the bible
in the new testament the old testament
if you look at historic documentation
it's proven that the 25th of december
has absolutely nothing to do with the
birth of jesus
nothing
not a shred of evidence
that shows
that jesus was born on the 25th of
december
in fact it was not until pope julius the
first he chose the date and why
to appease the pagans for a festival
that had for saturnalia which was to
celebrate saturn the sun god
this was a festival saturnalia
that they had in pagan rome
from before christianity even reached
rome
and what would they do on this festival
they would give gifts
seem familiar they would go and and
decorate a fern or a evergreen comfort
tree
with red berries
seem familiar
and they would party and they would
loosen the laws of decency to do very
indecent thing in those days
and the pagans were not willing to give
up this holiday
so pope julius the first 400 years after
jesus
he came up with the idea to take this
pagan holiday and bring it into the
christian religion
and the early christians they fought
this
they stood up against this oliver
cormwell
in the british parliament in 1659 he had
it banned
and the purists who came to america the
settlers who came to this country from
europe they did not celebrate it because
they also believed this was a pagan
festival in fact it was banned it was
illegal in the united states
when the pilgrims came here the purists
who wanted to follow the christian
religion properly they banned christmas
you can google and see pictures
of of those scans that you can find of
old postings that used to be posted
saying that this is not allowed in this
country and at that time what was going
to be america because it's a pagan
festival
if we look at
today
many christian
who are researchers who are people who
want to follow their religion they've
also spoken out against this pagan
festival
if we look at santa claus
who's now called santa and if you switch
a few letters it'll be satan
if you look at santa claus
there was no such tradition tied to
christmas
saint nicholas had nothing to do with
christmas they just took a man and they
took a nordic pagan legend about a man
who would come in green until coca-cola
made him red
and they made this tradition
from nowhere from pagan festivals
so how can
true christians
or jews or muslims celebrate a pagan
festival that has absolutely nothing to
do with jesus he's not the reason for
the season
this is all marketing
in fact
if we look at it from an islamic
perspective
if we look at the book
from islam
he mentions the quote
do not enter the kana's the churches of
the mushrikeen
on the days of their eid because the
punishment of allah the anger
descending upon them and today our imma
want to hold interfaith events in
churches on christmas and want to put
facebook page updates on happy hanukkah
and happy christmas and and happy easter
and marry this and marry that but what
do we find for abdullah
who says whoever lives in the land of
kuffar and celebrates their celebrations
and if they die they will be raised on
the day of judgment with them
this is
stay away from them this is from um
who and others they also as mentioned by
mom always they forbid to greet or
celebrate or to congratulate as if
jose and others mention the days of the
festivals of kuphar
now some people say oh but there's a
difference of opinion
i gave you the opinion of umar
of abdullah ibn
of
and of this sahaba
whose opinion is going to contradict
them find me a single sahabi rasool
allah did he celebrate them
did he congratulate them there were
yahoo nasa there
did he participate in them no
a single sahabi no we only have mana
forbidden rasulullah said do the
opposite of them
and then we have from sahaba clear
indications and from the amazing
scholars of islam and today somebody is
different opinion whose opinion some guy
who's never studied sharia a day in his
life sitting on his twitter account i
don't care about your opinion
but it gives from the kitab of allah
bring us
allah
so there is no difference of opinion it
is not permissible for muslims to
participate in them in these kind of
celebration or greet people on them this
is something known by consensus of this
ummah
i almost lost it when i seen you in rami
listen listen because
uh
uh is you know he's just arrived to the
to the table bro
let me give you a summary and to all the
viewers that made it late and missed
some of that video tldr we as muslims
just like arnold said we cannot partake
in christmas whatsoever
uh
this you know don't let society try to
guilt-trip you and liberalism guilt-trip
you like oh you know we should all you
know participate in interfaith events
and all this no bro
um
you know
you can come to the masjid alhamdulillah
you know you can come but i'm not gonna
go celebrate christmas with you in your
church there's a difference right
on me bro how you doing bro nice
sunglasses
the viewers who are wondering why the
heck am i wearing sunglasses indoors uh
my eyes swollen i just don't want you
guys to see that but regardless yes
celebrating christmas haram for many
reasons
but predominantly it has pagan origins
and you're going to follow the people
who claim they're worshiping the
birthday
of the son of god
[Laughter]
composure guys
composure
as i was saying
i can't i can't believe this is a live
stream bro
we
[Music]
we apologize for the unprofessionalism
but
romney's too swagged up bro yeah facts
but um
yeah as pagan origins you're gonna
follow the people that claim they're
celebrating the birthday of the son of
god
uh
in any way shape and form there's no way
to allow it and don't be the person
that's like
i just happen to put a certain type of
tree in my living room and decorate it
and put presents under it on the same
day as christians i just happen to do
that
bring that to allah and see how far that
gets you see how far in hell that will
take you may allah protect us
what do you say to a lot of people that
say oh it's not that bad bro i'm just
exchanging gifts i'm just wishing them
you know my my neighbor he's he's
christian he wishes me my buttock so why
can't i say merry christmas bro is it is
it really that deep bro
so one 100 percent is that dude yo dolma
no no bro he's just he's just hating bro
he's jealous that he doesn't have
sunglasses like no worries
so uh the problem is not giving gifts
the problem's not receiving gifts the
problem is
doing the same thing the christians do
which is celebrating the birthday of the
the son of god
and literally in the birthday of god
literally himself it makes no sense
and the prophet
he said beware of belittling the minor
sins
imagine belittling paganism
you're you're doing an act of paganism
of polytheism
and
celebrating the birthday of god is allah
and you're going to say i'm just
receiving gifts just receive gifts on
any other day if you receive gift on any
other day for any other reason we'd have
no problem with it receive your gifts
masha'allah
the fact that you're doing it on the
same day the same way the same style
walk talk and glasses as the christians
on that day
that's the problem with it so don't
comment try and be a little you know i'm
just receiving gifts you're not
you're not just receiving gifts
yeah we're imitating the disbelievers i
know bro i got my second question for uh
the physics professor angel over here
today we got 72 viewers in this live
stream bro how many likes should that be
300 300 bro still don't know how he does
the math bro but i'll probably never be
there so if you guys are here and you're
one of the 72 viewers what are you doing
smash that like button and uh inshallah
let's keep going so my next question to
you guys uh either of you can jump in
inshaallah uh let's say we got an
awkward situation we got a reverb right
someone who might even be coming from
catholicism right so they're christian
and now they all of a sudden they're in
this predicament now right i know angel
might have some first-time experience
with that it's the holidays they're like
yo why don't you just come over you know
you don't have to you know i understand
your faith it's kind of you know anti
you know christmas and all that you got
your own ways but just come over you
know come over we'll have a christmas
dinner
how do you approach that boom
ah
rami
do you have chapstick on too
i put vaseline on because my lips are
dry
bro my bad i'm trying the whole frame
here but
it's okay
romney got you stepping into the
feminine eh they got me slipping into my
feminine side boy
hmm
uh
repeat the question
so who is gay
my question i don't know repeat
is
when you have a an individual who is a
reaver right they're finally on the hawk
they're they're muslim right
and they are learning these things right
they're like okay i can't celebrate
christmas i can't celebrate birthdays um
or that at least they realize okay even
if i do
they're still haram i'm sinning right
because a lot of people
um it's better that they know it's a sin
and they do it
necessarily um per se then they don't
know it's a sin or they know it's a sin
but they're kind of into now they're
like oh it's not really that bad like
i'd rather you know it's a sin and you
sin knowing it's a sin and you repent
instead of being in delusion and telling
everyone oh birthdays are okay christmas
is okay my question to you is this this
reverb
who might be coming from christianity
their family might still be on
christianity they might still have
christmas
heck tomorrow for you because you're
christian um
maybe you might have uh some invitations
right so how do you how do you tackle
these bro because
knowing we're muslim we can't partake in
it but we don't want to be uh stuck
between a rock and a hard place between
family and the dean
right um
uh well you kind of put me in the
tough situation here haven't you
because you're gonna make me
air out like what i'm gonna be doing
and now i don't even know what i'm gonna
be doing is
is permissible or not
if you're comfortable with it you know
this is not legislative islamic
authoritative advice right this is just
something that you would say to
this reaver not even for you
okay so what i would say to the reaver
me being a reaver
is that
if your intention is to
[Music]
just spend time with your family
and you do this
on other days as well but let's say
your entire family is getting together
and this is not an often thing you don't
see your entire family all the time
then if your intention is
strictly just to see your entire family
regardless of what they're doing you
have no connection to what they're doing
then allah knows best but at the end of
the day that that still doesn't change
like
uh guilty by association
because you know you're still in
the place like me going to a club
but then me not drinking alcohol or
dancing or engaging in anything i'm
still there you know what i'm saying so
i'm getting by
association now is this the same
predicament
although
it seems like it would be you know
for all purposes it seems like it would
be
but again i think intention is very
important
and
overall like
what you plan on doing about it
in the future right like let's say
this is the intention you're doing this
now
and then you start thinking about and
you're like okay well this isn't exactly
the best thing that i should be doing
well what could i do next time around
and then the next time around it's all
about communication
and like really
communicating to your family and letting
them know hey i really don't
uh
i don't participate in christmas anymore
i don't believe in it i don't celebrate
i do none of that i love you guys i want
to spend time with you
but
if it has to be under these
circumstances then i'm sorry but
i won't be able to attend
you know
just like that but again that that's
that's like
following up because if
if the person can do it now
but if it's like already kind of
set in stone the intention is clear with
allah like
again allah knows best and allah knows
like what's in their hearts better than
they can even say so
what they think
good job bro that's a good answer
mashallah very concise from you rami uh
i got an answer i got a question for you
bro straight up um
you got a neighbor
forget you got a neighbor you got a
family member you got relatives they're
on they're muslim muslim right just like
you
um
every time christmas comes around you
see a wreath on their door you see a
christmas tree oh you know we're just
that's what everyone's doing you know
they they got the eggnog they got the
stockings right stuck for a lot but
everyone's doing it right
now they invite you or they don't invite
you you feel a pull that because
you know what they're doing is not
islamic and you want to save them from
the fire
then you got to tell them something
right you
allah might question you you don't know
the last one i don't thought i might
question you on why you just let that go
you just allowed it look at that smile
on the house race masha'allah blah blah
blah
what do you do bro what do you do do you
just
laugh and sit back like angel just just
laughing like look at this guy bro or
you're gonna be you know all up in them
kind of like hey this is what it is
do you take a diplomatic approach
because you don't want people to think
you know oh this guy's extreme and
automatically shut off and then continue
doing this
but you also don't want to be an enabler
and allow it you know you don't want to
be a bystander
yeah so you 100
you should bring it to them you should
just go to them even if it's something
like a few
days before whatever you invite them
over to your house for dinner or
a little whatever and then you guys you
know kind of chop it up chill for a
little bit then at the end last five
minutes the discussion you tell them
basically you know celebrating christmas
haram copying the kofarus haram you give
them the reasons for it
but those people
them not celebrating christmas
might not start
that that year that might them not
celebrate christmas might start the next
year because it's a long-term thing it's
not always going to be you tell people
to stop laughing at the fact that you're
wearing glasses and they keep laughing
sometimes you they have to be always
[Laughter]
it's okay would you guys rather see my
swollen eye
it's not that bad anymore it went down
bro i wouldn't even notice wallahi if
you didn't tell me
yeah it could also be that my brightness
is at like ten percent
yeah it did get a lot better
yeah
anyways let me take that one off but
then i'm not celebrating christmas no
i'm putting these guys still laughing
bro
okay bro
this is what happens when you try a
compromise man it never works out
i want you bro
like i want you on the alpha game bro
level 9000 i want you to go to a girls
valley with that eye no glasses look
that man in the eye
make him submit respectfully
just like that bro
but yeah so it's a long-term thing
people this is not a problem that
this the
the problem the root problem isn't the
fact that they're celebrating christmas
the root problem is the reason they
don't mind celebrating christmas they
don't know islam they don't have their d
they don't have the basics established
to establish the basics
it's not going to take one day and
they're like oh and maybe it will maybe
they have a bit of the basics and you
just need that little like
you know a little take the tree down you
know just
don't don't do exactly what they're
doing save the gifts for like
i don't know next year or something when
we're past christmas
and um
encourage them but if they still do it
that in the description you and your own
household don't at least don't allow it
in your own house
if you're the father
i like that i like that because you as
the wali the man the leader the the
imam you are responsible for everything
in your household
everything else is secondary do your
best to advise people respectfully beat
them by example and if they don't come
to the straight path you've done what
you could
do okay no i guess it's not gonna be too
long of an episode because we don't
wanna you know drop the point too long
so we will open it to uh the subscribers
you know for our normal uh q a thing at
the end a little earlier today than
normal so we're going to christmas
special for y'all not just playing it's
fine that's that's that's a joke guys
that's a terrible joke by the way bro
that's not even funny matter of fact i
don't see anyone laughing except the guy
in the glasses
and uh you
i don't know what you're laughing on her
or your joke i stopped for a lot bro
but with that being said just remember
guys today's episode was shorter usually
every week we have members only for the
live chat for the bulk of the episode
which is about 45 to 60 minutes um so
become a member support the channel link
in the description or the pinned comment
live chat
aside from that somebody take on the
floor while i change it up bro
all right
so hope you guys are not celebrating
christmas this year insha'allah a lot of
people unfortunately do i've been see
it's been it's been a trend for a while
unfortunately with muslims uh you'll see
the people on tiktok you'll see them
you'll see them celebrating and putting
their trees up and giving presents and
and being like i'm tired of these haram
police haram policing us telling us we
can't celebrate christmas you
do whatever you want
some things you do are going to take you
to hell some things you do are going to
take you to heaven
i'm telling you what allah and the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam have
commanded and have instructed us to do
to take us to jannah and to avoid us
going get your head in them if you want
to take that advice
go for it if you don't go for it at the
end of the day or at the end of this
world you know where it's going to take
you bro how is this our first comment
bro
are y'all like not listening
i think that i think they said happy
holidays specifically because it's not
necessarily merry christmas so it might
not be true um
true bro but i also don't like that they
misspelled mean and amen
yo and what what you were saying rami
these people
are these muslims they they need to have
hayah
yes like listen allah
puts a blankie over
the sins that we do and sometimes we do
things that we don't even know our sins
yeah so it's like if you're doing
something that takes you out of the foot
of islam it's not in islam there's
nothing about it it's islamic nothing
about it makes you a muslim it actually
makes you a kuffar because we just
we literally clearly just outlined it we
allowed sheikh usman even farooq to even
go in and say his part masha allah
all right so with that being said if you
understand
then like
if you're still deciding to do it like
don't go out there and say it at least
at least the bare minimum like just
don't say it out
you know but then again i feel like the
people who are saying you know and who
are
you know uh
celebrating it is due to ignorance so
may allah guide them though yeah i agree
bro
i'm delighted
for the haram police indeed
is it the last episode
for the for this 2021 uh no bro y'all
are getting a surprise episode on monday
with uh a youtuber who is chinese and he
revered to islam not gonna give much
more info on that
you got you guys gonna eat roast chicken
though from goku black
i don't know what about you
roast chicken
i'm gonna eat whatever is there bro
maybe whatever my family has
what i mean where are you permissibly
obviously if it's
yeah yeah um hopefully i would love that
but no promises
we'll see okay
next question as we vote you through
randomly laughing the video reminds me
of your video number 20 about black
magic
i mean i'm gonna accept it from us
okay both of you what do you think about
this
honestly i don't know the ruling
yeah i if i remember correctly i think
it's fine because it's not really
it's not like celebrating it you're just
like going into a new year like you're
celebrating another year here but
a lot of them
i don't think it's imitating the kofa to
some extent but
make sure you guys do research islam qa
is a good website
um i mean obviously obviously the
partying and drinking and the stuff that
happens on here is harambe yeah that's
official official
i mean if you think about it too like
would it really be beneficial because
even the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
has said and i think he said it or maybe
it's just i don't know um a lot of them
correct me if i'm wrong
but uh it's
we should be going to sleep like right
after isha
and i'm sorry but 12 p.m
or 12 a.m at night is not
going to sleep right after asia yeah i
should travel usually when asia ends
i like that i like that
but that depends on what madame you're
falling bro so yeah yeah
nationalism is haram
ah
yeah man that is
yeah yeah
nationalism is kind of like tribalism
so muslim celebrities put up christmas
trees
from that and may allah guide these
individuals that are in the public eye
to not do this next year
and to start you know not making these
mistakes
[Music]
asked where is gabriel romani he's
currently traveling not going to say
where but he will be on the on the
channel soon inshallah
i should put on vaseline that's exactly
what i put on
i'm pretty sure
do you put chapstick or vaseline on like
regularly
i'm starting to yeah because this
happened like yesterday so i'm starting
to put it on what happened just like
super dry lips yeah bro i touched it and
it like cracked and i'm like hell no
that's usually a sign of dehydration so
if you take care of the hydration aspect
then you don't really have to use
chapstick or vaseline
yeah but it could also be dehydration
caused from stuff like sleep apnea bro
because a lot of people wake up with a
with a lot of dry lips
sleep apnea will do that to you bro
you'll feel thirsty you'll feel hungry
you'll wake up with acid reflux and all
this
um
you guys know
yeah bro yo that guy is a g listen
may allah elevate him allah protect him
he's a g i'm not going to speak too much
on him we're not going to go into this
because i know you're curious you're
probably like yo who's that but i'm not
trying to get this demonetized bro if
you know you know
with this world
and life every day is permanent test
so we need to expect challenges and
expect a silliness
to keep getting worse
correct
perfume magnesium get complimented
your savages is something bro all right
listen i've never smelled that one i bet
you it's bomb though
all right so when it comes to perfumes
colognes
everyone's gonna be different
uh the one that i like the most is uh
very sexy
for him platinum
it's a victorious secret
perfume for men and it's like the
platinum version and i know it sounds
like yo like you serious bro
[Music]
it's the best smelling
perfume
for men that i've ever
oh man that i've ever smelled in my life
so that's the only one that i rock
okay
i'll show you like that actually you get
the bottle bro i'll give i'll give you
all my uh top five so number one uh one
million by paco rabanne number two
uh all team by usain laurent ysl peeps
y'all you already know
uh let's see
number three
you wanna young you show that bro
yeah
oh and it's like it's like this like
purplish
type liquid y'all can't really even see
the color
um
there we go victoria's secret
uh number three here on the back
bring that closer bro
very sexy
platinum for him
honestly like listen i'm not even
playing i don't play
this stuff right here
there we go number three uh georgia
armani
aqua
uh i'll just i'll just leave it at that
three we'll probably do it in depth i
know rami got bare you know so we're
going to that leave it leave it at
soon three persona um recently i've been
using less cologne using more atar you
know gabriel arumani he got me some some
nice utter when i went to uh
dubai and i'm still using it mashallah
uh and yeah bro
i thought it was like
you know what could you explain that um
i know a musk is or a mess
i don't know i thought it was like this
it's like a natural essential oil if i'm
not mistaken and it's something that
it's it's like a scent right and we put
it on and
um it's good bro so i'll send you some
inshallah i'll be down for that
inshallah yeah
inshallah bro
but the unsexy answer i know you guys
are waiting for this is that it does
affect your testosterone to some degree
right
most of these things do
i gotta fix that i got a fix for that do
it on your clothes not your skin
exactly if you know you know bro i'm on
that too but a lot of people they
they're directly put on their skin yes
you're gonna smell good but at the same
time is it worth the drop in your
t-count i don't know you tell me
definitely not
how to respond when someone says merry
christmas
uh well one you don't have to respond if
you feel like you do have to respond
that's probably the beta inside you from
all this social conditioning telling you
that you gotta you know always say the
most politically correct thing but you
also don't want to be an a-hole about it
so what i would say
happy holidays or something you know or
you too or something but at the same
time i don't know if islamically that's
correct because you're still
reciprocating it to some degree i don't
know what it would be i personally i
haven't gone through this uh this
encounter what about you just smiling
smiles
and it's not glued
like a creep or what
yeah bro i just smile
like
someone it's like someone complimenting
you
it's like me being like yo fire
that hairstyle man it really brings out
like your features man it looks it makes
your face look really masculine
you could be like
you just smile bro he's like
you know like i appreciate you you don't
have to say nothing
it's body language it's the unspoken
language the language without words
that's true bro um there was a study
done they basically concluded that about
90 of all communication is non-verbal so
it's sub-communication so that basically
means
people might be influenced by you and
what you say more by how you say it and
how you look in your body language than
actually what you say
so i'm just putting it out there don't
put too much effort into what you're
saying all the time
next question for ah no
all right what did your family say when
you accepted islam
some of them
were cool with it
some of them
were not cool with it
everyone is all on board now and they
all accept it
they all love it um and they're all
getting very
curious
at asking questions so
inshaallah inshaallah they will be
guided as well
i've been i've been told
i've been told that my eyebrows
my nose
my facial features my beard
bro
the way my neck comes in like this
and then like
nah i'm just playing but um my facial
features in general yeah i've been told
i love it
are you from london
is that barack obama
obama
bro that's the thing barack hussein
obama is actually his name so i don't
know if he was muslim at one point if
he's still muslim
oh yeah i think
he was
sheesh
mauricious man
from the islands
going on this floor
um i think the real question is how can
god be
independent and dependent how can god
not need any food or drink but need food
and drink how can god be an eternal ever
living being with a birthday and a death
day how can god be murdered and and
stripped naked and beaten and put up on
a cross by his own creation and still be
called god
i think that's the real question and
go look at what jesus was preaching even
in in the new testament which we don't
think is authoritative uh to any degree
to be honest but go read what the new
testament says
go read john 17 3 where he says that
they may know eternal life and the only
true god and you the father as the only
true god
and jesus christ you have sent
he said the only true god is the father
and he was just sent by god like a
prophet and messenger so go read your
own scripture bro don't listen to what
the church tells you
read the bible
and see what was actually said
your sunglasses
yeah but i do want to say a quick
linguistic you know
uh grammar nazi whatever you guys want
to call me but a lot of people say yeah
just to like you know you want to just
appease to and trigger the christians
right so you say oh yeah i do accept
jesus as savior you know like just to
you know peace to them because you say
oh yeah because jesus is going to save
us when he destroys the jail listen bro
islam is going to destroy the jail no
doubt about it but savior linguistically
in in in christianity it basically means
they you know saving you from your sins
from the hell fire that's not what isam
is going to do no one's going to do that
bro except allah so just wanted to
clarify that
is looking cool mashallah
i don't know what that means bro would
they fame
is that like what you're calling my
sunglasses
because it's a nose
monica's asking actually victoria's
secret bro like actually yeah yeah yeah
yeah the the cologne is from the
victoria's ego the perfume it's it's
full men
which is weird because they don't
usually have things for men at all but
foreign
the lighting but it looks like an army's
wearing lipstick no bro he's just
wearing lipstick don't worry about that
don't trip on that
yourself so hard the divine son did when
he assumed a human nature
bro like it's it's just
it's just contradiction after a
contradiction
a fully human person eats
yeah exactly fully human which means not
fully god which means not god
which means go read your scripture
this is interesting
one
christian say that you know because it's
like
in in the bible it literally says it
like
jesus was asked about the hour
the final hour and he's like that's
only the father has that only god has
that
it's like huh
interesting
interesting
guys i just want to say i'm still
addressing questions from 10 minutes ago
because there's there's too many
questions to to go through um and i want
to leave it you know subscribe only so
if you do send a super chat it'll come
and give us a notification above so i'll
be sure to inshallah guarantee that it
gets answered aside from that i'm just
picking random questions
and we're probably gonna wrap it up too
in like 10 inch minutes
oh no again this is a repeat
yeah it's a repeat
yep
smiling
boys
smiling is it offensive no i believe
speaking the truth is something we
should all do is it politically correct
hell no
you should do it anyway it's just a
matter of how you do it you don't need
to be you know rude about it
but most people want the truth bro
and some people think they want the
truth
and a few people really don't want the
truth and if it's the last category
forget them bro
i'd say first tell them
that you don't celebrate it and then if
they get curious
then throw it at them
you know like don't just shove it down
the throat yeah
holly can you guys host
three episodes for you is not enough
come on now
i didn't know what to do when giving a
gift from co-workers this week talk to
fitna who like
take the gift
yeah that's a good question because
a gift is a gift that's not really you
celebrating christmas you know what i
mean it's kind of like if someone like
let's say someone makes money in a haram
way
and you have nothing to do with it
and then they give you a gift using that
money or they give you that money as a
gift
it wouldn't be hard for you to take that
because it's a gift to you you have
nothing to do with the actual like reba
or anything
as far as i know you can tell them
straight up
like yeah i don't celebrate christmas i
think i got you
yeah you know my bad for can you ask for
all yeah no worries that was a good
addition masha allah actually i was
going to say that before i completely
forgot so i'm glad you mentioned it i
was just going to say um that's the best
thing to do if someone says you know
merry christmas you say oh thank you but
i don't celebrate christmas
less than i do
yeah
they still want to give you the gift you
know accept it and then you can repay
the favor at another time but you're
repaying the favor for the gift
not for
christmas
for the gift
gifts exchange
what religion
was i previously
i was born
into
catholicism then i
kind of started going to christianity
left that became atheists for a long
time
started getting to the new age stuff
buddhism hinduism
taoism a whole bunch of crazy stuff a
whole bunch of crazy stuff and then i
got back into christianity tried to
release
and from all the studying and all the
reading and all the questions that i had
just
here i am
yeah i am in islam
allah has got it
so david's still at it again bro david i
just want to say one thing um we don't
really have time we got a lot of lovely
viewers and subscribers that are
supporting us we don't got time you're
making yourself look like a fool so if
you really want to you know talk to us
or or or you want to challenge our
beliefs and ideologies i'm open to it on
god i'm open to all of us are open to it
right um but you're probably not gonna
but our email
thc3
muslims
gmail.com so just take our name
gmail.com send us an email
and uh we'll see you there if you're
serious
nah bro
email us only if you
actually
are curious
because this
if he emails us it's just gonna be like
trying to refute or trying to
uh basically
say that he's right about this isn't
that that we need to change like this
this is not what we're doing here we're
not
we're not those people we're here to
spread the truth true if you're curious
about it then
okay
thank god
either way bro that's that's where
you're gonna belong bro if you wanna get
our attention from this moment onward
but bro the atheist they're not they're
not pissing me off lately it's is the
questions in the in the comments bro
they're just
it's ridiculous bro it's i don't know
what to say bro and i respect i have
respect for christians i i see them as
human beings and and i'm one with them
listen we all live in a society with
different people and different cultures
different races so on and so forth but
at the same time some of the christians
the things they comment it's really like
bro are you serious like
where did where did this come from bro
yeah
no he didn't i also believe that isa
name
where did jesus even come from
i mean i mean i mean
i mean jesus is just a translation
you know it's like
maddox
what is it
bro he looks like an actor if anything
not a cool guy
first you had the blind quran recited
i'm going to abstain from responding to
that
i like that you're smiling not bro
smiling
sister santa finally made it yeah and
jazakallahu
man
yeah it's a business bro big bucks to be
made
a question for mommy from raymond
do i comb my hair well i mean i keep my
hair curly so combing it with defeat it
being curly
you don't call them curly hair
i think this is for on home bro
is it allowed to enter victoria's secret
hello if you have a wife and not
how did you get your hands on that on
that perfume bro that's honestly you can
buy it online you can go to perfume
mania or something like that and just
get it direct like that without having
to go to the website i understand i know
i can bro i'm asking what did you do
that one was actually a gift from a
friend
i like that bro
i'm not trying to put you on the spot
i'm just joking i know bro
but last thing you said you would go in
depth on the top five perfumes and the
last thing gabriel did a review on
bracelets of kisara perfume it really
got me hyped has gabriel
talked about it to you i believe he gave
me that as a sample
like in a box i just didn't open it yet
bro
it's been uh it's been two months but
that's the thing you were talking about
right
the um
no no no he gave me utter like a lot of
people okay so that is different
than perfume either
author's not going to come in like a
perfume box oh there's like a little
tiny like vial bra
how did it smell we'll uh we'll do a
review soon insha'allah
research these companies you're spending
your money on family
okay
i know it's ridiculous bro
it was um you remember
paul
from blogging yeah
blogging theology
let me see if i could find this
you know sucks
that's funny
what was it
he said um saying jesus is god is like
using pronouns nowadays
sure
so there's all okay he put this one
picture up
and there's one guy he asked this other
guy
he's like who is jesus and the guy that
he's asking is obviously a christian
he's like god
and he's like did god ever die he's like
no
he's like all right then who died on the
cross jesus
i remember that i saw that video
actually
i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't say that
either to be honest
[Music]
why the knife
why the knife bro
every christian should have to read the
quran i would even say every christian
should at least read the bible because
the way they're talking is if they
didn't even read the bible once
um know your own religion
if it's not islam
you're going to come to a point where
things don't add up if you're
truly trying to be guided
and you truly ask the creator the one
creator to guide you allah insha allah
this thing is crazy that
the book has been altered
you can't find the original text
so why would you follow an altered book
and the real
christians the ones who
actually study their religion
know that their book has been altered
but still choose to
follow their book and then
if i if i'm remembering correctly the
part that has been altered is a chapter
which
is talking all about the afterlife and
supposedly i think the reason why they
removed it is because people were
focusing too much on the afterlife it's
like
it wasn't upon them to remove
a part of this which if it really was
the word of god
if it really was
what what in their right minds
would give humans
the right to feel like okay we can
actually remove this part because you
know what the mass they're paying too
much attention to this part we need them
to pay attention to this
part here so let's remove this fight
come on bro
and bro i just want to say that uh
you know christianity rami said this in
class um there's there's akita without
sharia like there's the belief aspect of
it which is like okay you believe in
christ salvation all this you're saved
and you can do whatever but there's no
sharia like there's no governance
there's no laws and i think that's
really dangerous bro because it takes it
diffuses responsibility in you from
becoming a law-abiding citizen and
having some type of objective morality
and having a code to live your life
i also want to say that people are
writing
exactly people writing now rami looks
cool in the glasses other people are
writing best to remove the glasses
bro i got a question for y'all why is it
never about what rami wants
why is it always about what you guys
want
yeah
facts
facts bro mommy looks good with or
without glasses bro
i just thought i raised a lot of leave
with princesses
i'm suppressing you remember that bro
yeah i think it's assistant
what he said he said she
yeah he said bro
he said she i said bro to angel oh okay
you call that curly
looks like you just woke up bro what if
he did just wake up bro that's
definitely curly bro
i mean it is definitely curly hair this
is what curly hair does it's all over
the place yeah
i think we should get off how i look and
just get back to the topic bro like who
cares what glasses no glasses curly hair
straight like let's move on please
as soon as you said that someone's like
last one
okay guys uh we got two more minutes
left
any question that you want addressed and
answered super chat and we'll answer
inshallah or if you remember comment
down below aside from that i'm just
gonna pick like two random
subscriber answers but do you guys have
anything else to say bro
no
no
bro let me ask you a math question if we
got 132 viewers on this live stream how
many likes should we have
oh man on hill angel bro i'm gonna need
your help here man my mouth isn't up
there yet call a friend
yeah
phone hey phone me and tag me in coach
all right
yo
hey yo what's good bro lego all right
a million dollar question and i just got
asked if we have 132 viewers how many
likes should we have kind of stuck here
man
what are you gonna do with the million
dollars if you if you win bro i'll give
you a percentage okay we'll talk about
that after just help me out no no no no
no first you gotta donate your saudi
girl okay okay yeah that's facts that's
facts
all right so repeat the question we have
132 viewers how many legs should we have
all right so if you multiply that and
then divide it by this put this over
here to the second power and the
exponent don't don't forget to carry the
eight bro
yes yes yes thank you giza
all right so if you do this then you
round to the fourth and um
500
500 500 500 final answer 500. there we
go there we go 500 ding ding ding
correct answer right there all right so
we got first super chat first question
out of the box
do the benefits of jiu-jitsu outweigh
the physical health risks let's go
yes
and you can limit the physical health
risks if you train
smart and you train with people
who have good intentions and they're not
trying to
you know destroy your limbs
james bro come on man like
i'm not a math major so i don't know how
he got that either but he's an expert
we took our logic from the christians
don't
question the process
right
[Music]
everything in life is an opportunity
cost so the key is balance and just
making dua in subju to allah for
making things easy and allowing me to
continue nowhere am i saying i'm doing
this perfectly by any means i'm just
sometimes i feel like i'm holding on uh
by a thread that's just tearing at its
seams bro but you just got to keep going
or assist you just got to keep going
insha'allah
allah make it easy for you bro
i mean
okay last question and then i'm just
gonna pick one random one
okay
well you guys bring a share to the on
the podcast i mean it really depends to
be honest
like we don't believe in what the shares
believe in and we know that like when we
bring someone on that we're giving them
a platform to preach what they want
so i mean if it's like a discussion
debate style then i mean why not you
know we believe we have the truth and uh
maybe we'll bring someone like furry
responds or something like that and go
against uh one of the more prominent
like speakers or you know scholars
uh that would be nice that'd be nice but
other than just kind of having them on
to chop it up and chill
i don't see the point in it to be honest
we're not gonna let them just come and
teach what they want
i agree bro all right so
fortunately or unfortunately
however much you guys like us
the time is now to end this stream until
next friday inshallah uh yeah i don't
think we'd ever not bring a shia but
we'd definitely bring an ex shia before
for sure bro no doubt about at least
extra that's on the hook um yeah okay
last question bro i'll fudge it bro we
like you today
so this is uh let's answer this last
question bro any tips on how to keep a
great beard
beard oil
um
co-wash
so co-wash is uh you're you're washing
it with conditioner only
not with shampoo wash with shampoo like
once a week
do a co-wash like
a few times within that and if you're
not doing a co-wash just rinse it with
water
and then reapply the beard oil
use uh the boar's
voice head bristle brush
very very
very nice
beard
and
that's pretty much it you know
i know romney was saying that he found
the thing about not grooming not cutting
the beard
um
i'll let you guys do that
but we definitely should
trim the mustache because listen even a
long mustache
doesn't it doesn't look good in my
opinion it sucks
because you got the hair going in like
into your mouth you got the hair poking
your lips and it just
raymond appreciate the work you do man
except from us will you host muscle
broken inshallah we just don't know how
to get a hold of him so if any of you
guys can give us some contacts let us
know the three muslims at gmail.com one
word
and we will make it happen inshaallah
all right with that being said i think
this is the time for now just a reminder
please do not celebrate christmas do
your best to put the bean first it might
be uncomfortable it might not be what
makes you feel the best it might mean
that you're going to put people in an
awkward scenario and predicament but you
got to do what's right first and
foremost
and with that being said let's let
stevie wonder here recite surah class
i think i think our special guest is
waiting for us bro so we gotta we gotta
step here all right both of them all
right
and that being said actually you know
it's actually
well actually what the sahaba did is
they would recite
as far as i know but